our next guest oscar nominated director
baz lerman he is one of hollywood's most
celebrated directors and is known for
his fantastical and glamorous movies
like moulin rouge romeo and juliet and
the great gatsby and that's just to name
a few now he has taken on the story of
the legendary singer elvis presley in
the new film elvis premiering on june
24th in this scene austin butler
performs the iconic song jailhouse rock
take a look
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of people say i'm a fan and then
you know but well
seriously
i think i gave chandler our producer a
picture of me as elvis which i've used
like of course for halloween over and
over again so it's great to see you now
look at that there it is right there
i don't get how he can be so young
[Laughter]
are you having one beer a day
now speaking of being a fan it seems
like you are a fan of iconic figures uh
gatsby romeo and juliet canal elvis what
drew you to elvis um and also were you a
fan before you made this film you know
when i was a kid we had the cinema we
had a theater house in a tiny tiny town
and it used to be like the elvis matinee
so i was a kid fan and he was in my life
a bit when i was born dancing i think
burning love dropped and i'd go over
with the records hey put burning up
you know but i but if my fandom faded i
went on to other things of course but i
always loved the way say shakespeare
would take like a historical figure and
explore a bigger idea and i always
thought if you want to look at america
in the 50s 60s and the 70s
right here's this great way of exploring
it because he's there one way or the
other the good the bad the ugly yeah and
that's where it started it was only when
i thought about the idea of colonel tom
parker never colonel never tom never
parker played by a guy called tom hanks
yeah you know the cell
and the soul you know that's america
that's what i wanted to explore i rather
you called tom hanks personally to
recruit him into the role is that normal
practice for you uh and what did he say
actually you you know getting someone
like tom hanks to commit to a role like
this you can take months i sat with him
i knew him socially a bit i thought
about this huge character that is
colonel tom barker who could play that
you know like he's kind of like a giant
clown-like figure with you know a
chainsaw and i sat with tom
i told him about the figure of parker
it might have been
20 minutes at the end of it he said if
you want me i'm your guy wow wow and i
walked out and i said to my guys did he
just say yes
and i think he just said yes and i think
what was he was so attracted to the
character but he also wanted to play
i mean it's like america's favorite dad
wanted to show that actually he could be
disturbing right since he's an
unsettling character
he's he's sinister but i have to tell
you elvis is many things to many people
visual there were parts of his history
that i did not know and the way you sort
of crawl through his life and i say
crawl because it's very emotional
and deal with race deal with
what some people have said it's been
cultural approaches sure absolutely it's
really interesting why did you tackle it
the way you did because i mean
first of all i realized yesterday when i
was at graceland yesterday we were there
for two days i realized it was five
years ago to the sort of day that i went
down there to start researching you know
i'm the ultimate outsider i mean i lived
it i found those that scene
in the gospel tent where the preacher
puts his hand that was told to me by a
gentleman called sam bell
sadly passed last year you know so i
kind of lived it but i think
you know a lot of the artists in
the film who play you know kelvin
harrison jr who plays bb king or yola
who plays sister rosetta but i mean the
mother of rock and roll really the
inventor of rock and roll she's in the
movie yeah well little richard played by
alton mason i think yola says it so
eloquently which is you know you've got
to show
i mean appropriation is like it just
came out of a vacuum as opposed to
you've got to show all i did was show
the context
what is the lineage yeah what is the
real journey of it and i discovered a
lot and i hope a lot of people will
discover things they didn't realize
that's all i did tell the story well we
do have we we have pictures that will
show elvis with mahalia jackson elvis
with brook benton elvis with uh bb king
it was
he
synthesized yeah this is an incredible
picture there's elvis yeah look at that
with jackie wilson right mr excitement
there he is
um and and i think that what and of
course fats domino who elvis in the film
says is the true king he says
he hated that phrase yeah no of us hated
the fact
rock and roll he said he said i'm not
the king of rock and roll and then he
turns to fat storm and he says fats come
here he said this is the real king of
rock and roll i mean there's a
difference between what say the colonel
the seller the promoter yeah the
audience right put on someone and who
they really are
i think what austin butler's great
achievement is
is that he
he humanizes him i mean he he is in the
end it's incredibly vulnerable yeah i
mean you know the shame of the dad going
to jail um growing up so poor yeah um
yeah being in
one of the few white houses in in
in the black community yeah certain
stage and then losing his mother
so early it's the humanity of him that i
think is lost in the mix
of the duality of the superstar and the
humans that's right as i got to say the
film is a triumph people should see it
in theaters because it's a wall of
beautiful sound and speaking of that
time
so make sure you go check it out i care
about it you know what goes out of their
houses and going into the theater and
you know what i love my jets and and i
love my dinosaurs there you go you know
man can i have that man appreciate it so
much
it is in theaters fridays june 24th
i'm just getting that